OK, what I have for you next.
I have to admit this is a pleasure to watch.
I am really enjoying the entire Trump administration
just falling all over itself to try to deny
this blockbuster bombshell story about Donald
Trump calling troops who died in combat.
Losers and suckers.
I already told you when the Atlantic reported
it.
Trump denied it.
Then the AP corroborated it.
They kept denying it.
Fox confirmed it.
Chaos at Fox News.
CNN now has quadruply confirmed it and they
have no idea what to do.
And at one of those Gong Show press briefings
Friday, Trump said both that the source for
the story doesn't exist and that the sources
for the story are lying.
So hold on.
Are they real and lying or they don't exist
and are made up by the media outlets?
All four media outlets, which is it?
And this is amazing.
And Trump barely able to speak.
You will hear him say here three and a half
years.
It just makes no sense.
He's making no sense.
I've gone after me more than any president
in the United States in history, in the history
of the United States.
And it's a shame.
It's a shame.
And despite that, we've done more in the first
three and a half years than any administration.
There's been no administration that's done
more when you add it all up.
There's been no despite all of the horrible
political games that have been played.
But there's nobody that's been that's been
able to do what I've done.
And that includes the Great Mission Act, because
what Obama passed was a joke.
It was a joke.
And we took it to a level that nobody thought
possible.
And that includes accountability.
So it's a disgrace that somebody is allowed
to write things like that.
It could have been.
A lot of times the sources aren't sources
that don't exist, and sometimes the sources
are just people that are disgruntled.
Former so-called employees, as Aaron Rouper
said on Twitter.
It's a sort of choose your own adventure here,
is it?
There are fake sources made up by the media
outlets.
All for.
Or is it that these are disgruntled former
employees who are lying?
The grief, the briefing didn't get any better.
Here, Trump started to attack his former chief
of staff, John Kelly, under suspicion that
John Kelly might be the source.
But the question Trump was asked was, did
you disparage American soldiers?
And Trump, instead of denying it, attacks
John Kelly and then says that also the weather
was the reason why he wasn't able to go to
that cemetery in France.
The fog prevented him from going to honor
the troops, a claim which has been widely
debunked since then, even able to function
in the last number of months.
He was not able to function.
He was sort of a tough guy by the time he
got eaten up in this world.
It's a different world than he was used to.
He was unable to function.
And I told him, John, you're going to have
to go.
Please give me a letter of resignation.
And we did that.
And now he goes out and where the bed mouse.
Now there are people that are jealous.
There are people that are upset that they're
not here anymore.
There are people that we've done an incredible
job.
The virus came in and now we're doing an incredible
job again.
We're going to build it up bigger than it
was before the virus came in.
But I don't know that it was him.
I haven't seen that.
I mean, I see Anonymous.
But it could have been a guy like a John Kelly
because he was.
Because it's for you.
So you understand.
He was a very you look at some of his news
conferences.
What happened to him?
He got eaten alive.
He was unable to handle the pressure of this
job.
This job was a tough job.
Mark Meadows doing a great job, but Kelly
was unable to do that.
And as far as that day, I mean, we have so
much proof as to going to the we I went to
Paris and the environs and I was all set to
go.
They had a rainstorm, the likes of which you
rarely see.
The fog was so great.
It was it was as dense as I've ever seen.
Just unable to stick to any topic ever.
Then Trump said again that Lee Atlantic story
is a hoax, ignoring, of course, that at this
point it had been corroborated by the AP and
Fox News.
And after this briefing by CNN as well, you
spoke earlier about the Atlantic story and
you reference the number of administration
officials have come out to support you.
We have 11 people.
I was just told.
I was just so we have 11 people.
There is nobody that feels more strongly about
our soldiers, our wounded warriors, our soldiers
that died in war than I do.
It's a hoax.
Just like the fake dossier was a hoax, just
like the Russia, Russia, Russia is a hoax.
It was a total hoax.
No collusion.
Just like so many other things.
It's a hoax and you'll hear more of these
things totally unrelated as we get closer
and closer to election.
The magazine is a failing magazine.
And nobody called me.
Nobody called me from the magazine, said you
have a comment about it.
They just write whatever they want to write
because they figure you can't get sued, you
can't get sued.
But it's very it's a very hard bringing lawsuit.
Of course, the other things Trump mentions
also aren't hoaxes.
The dossier was real with lots of accurate
things and many things that are still unconfirmed.
The Russia thing was not a hoax.
Dozens were arrested.
The Mueller report couldn't exonerate Trump.
The Senate select report pointed out that
a lot of the allegations were true, so none
of them were hoaxes.
And then Trump wrapping up hilariously by
assailing the reporters in the room as children,
asking terrible questions and then bizarrely
thanking them for their presence.
Biden getting ask questions that are really
meant for a child to answer.
Anybody could answer.
And I look at the level of questions that
you people ask.
I mean, honestly, it's disgraceful.
So I want to thank you all very much.
We appreciate it.
And we're doing very well.
We're very, very proud of what's happened
with respect to the economy.
I just love that your questions are childish.
You people are disgraceful.
Thank you very much for being here at my press
briefing, which couldn't exist without you
actually being here.
This is a man falling apart.
And this was only part of the press briefing.
I want to kind of separated into stuff related
to the soldier's story and then other things
that happened at the rally.
I'm sorry, that's a Freudian slip.
Other things that happened at the briefing
right after this.
Because there is much more
to discuss.